our definition
like we talked about the median and our
definition of that
we called it the middle score but we
said that's not the best way to describe
it
we would say that the median
right it's the number that divides up
your
set of data it divides the scores
into a bottom half of the top half right
in other words it divides them right
down the middle
into an equal set right so into two
equal sections
right yeah the bottom half top half and
then the same size is the same number of
people scores data points in both hearts
okay and then we extended that we said
well okay if you look at the bottom half
and you look at the second half you do
this again
right you get quartiles
right so these are exactly the same in
terms of dividing scores but instead of
two equal sections you get
three four four four there are three
there are three quarters okay think
about this right
there's one median which gives you two
sections
there are three quartiles which gives
you four sections does that make sense
so four equal sections
okay now therefore and you can sort of
guess by the name right
if you then extended this again and said
well
what if i want a finer division of my
set of data
right deciles is not two equal sections
or four equal sections but
ten equal sections now follow the
pattern right
there's only a single median there's um
three quarter isles q
one q two q three how many deciles are
there
eight no nine nine nine
let's just say the decimals are the
dividers right
to divide up something into ten
difference you need nine
dividers nine walls between them so
there are nine deciles so you might say
there's one of these guys
there's uh three of these guys
and then there are nine deciles
going on one last step the idea of
a percentile okay you don't need me to
tell you
what this next one's gonna be right
you're gonna divide all your scores into
it's a very dark day outside um
okay now follow with me there are
there's one median
three quartiles nine deciles how many
percentiles are there
okay so put your pants down and i want
you to think with me
right the way we would the way we would
say this when we
would use this language is to say oh
you guys are in the 97th percentile of
say
you know household income okay now what
does that mean um don't write this down
yet just think about this sentence with
me
um you're in the 97th
percentile
okay now what that means is because you
divided up all of your scores into 100
equal sections
and you're on the 97th one right
how much of the population is below
you
i should come back to this guy right if
i said you were on the first quartile
right how much what percentage of the
population is
below you if you're on the first quarter
all right let me draw them here we go
right so i would say you're on the first
quartile right
so that means 25 percent is below you
does that make sense if you're the like
remember the quartile is not a section
the quartile is a number
right so it's like you're right there
and here are all of the people
beneath you does that make sense if i
said you're the median that means
there's going to be
50 below you okay so
now when you think about this how many
people are below you
97. okay good so what you've got here is
a very fine way of describing
where are you in proportion to everyone
else okay now
it was quite a bit of work to work out
what a quarter was so you've got
everything in order you know do all of
this
decision percentiles you will not be
asked to calculate
find what these are just too much work
we have programs we have
you know a spreadsheet will do this for
us okay what you do need to do
is to be able to read and interpret
these off a graph you've already been
given
okay so have a look at that piece of
paper you have in front of you
and um this thing looks weird so i want
to i want to teach you how to read it
now you'll need a ruler so what are you
looking at let's just start with the
easy things um what's the title of this
graph
okay cool so we're looking for bmi for
um
you know two to twenty year old boys
men okay have a look at the axes you've
got over here on the left-hand side
that's the bmi going up okay and then
on the bottom you've got age okay so how
old are these people
right so what i'm going to do is um
show you how to read this thing by
trying to answer some of these questions
right
now just before i get to the first
question these wiggly lines which seem
to be like the important thing about it
right
what they represent you might talk about
the 97 percentile before
let's talk about the 95th because that's
the top one over there
okay i need a little bit more of the
graph
there we go okay so let's picture
let's start over here at age two okay if
your bmi
is here right that means so like
or 19 and a half or something like that
okay
yeah yeah it is uh it's more than me
it's considerably more than me too
um if you are at this bmi at this age
right that means you are on the 95th
percentile for bmi now thinking back to
what this
mean this means that means that 95
of the population has a smaller bmi than
you does that make sense
so if you're on the 95th percentile
which comes all the way down to here
you have a very high bmi does that make
sense
now now the number for your bmi the
expected number for your bmi it changes
throughout your life
right so for example where's the median
which one of the look at the colors
which one is the median
the median in between is the 50th
percentile
right the median is the 50th percentile
because that means 50 is below
and 50 is above so it's this green one
in here okay
so you could say oh well like a normal
person who's right in the middle of the
bell curve
they're gonna have this bmi over here
according to their age
okay does that make sense all right so
now you have a rough idea
let's go into the details the first
question says and um you'll need your
ruler for this
and i'm expecting the reason i
photocopied this out so you can draw all
over this because you can't do it
obviously
with your textbook it says what is the
bmi for 12 year old boys in the 85th
percentile
okay so have a look um ages across the
horizontal axis
right so i see 12 is there right
now with your ruler then draw up a line
that shows all of the bmis and
percentiles for 12 year olds okay it
should look something like
this
okay so the way i read this now
is i say okay if i want to know what the
for example what the median bmi of 12
year old boys is
then i go as we were just saying to that
um over there to that green line which
is
where the 50 is following and then i'm
going to go all the way to the left and
i'm going to read a number off okay so
that's how i'm using this graph
now i don't actually want the um the
50th percentile i don't want the median
what am i after for this question
85th so have a look from the top those
curvy lines that's the third curvy line
down
right so i've i'm going to mark that in
yep
and therefore i'm going to go across all
the way and it looks to me like that's a
bmi
of 21. by the way if you want to um
well i mean only the boys can do it for
this particular graph but if you want to
position yourself just in case you can't
remember
um bmi is weight divided by
so remember height squared uh
and the height has to be in meters okay
all right so i've answered that first
one
the bmi for 12 year olds in the 85th
percentile is 21.
okay let's keep going what percentage of
15 year olds have a body mass index
that's less than 17.1 so again
i'm going to go to my the relevant axis
bmis are all on the left-hand side right
listen enough
because mr anderson will come um so
where's 17.1 on the left hand
axis 17.1
it's going to be about there right you
can see that um
in between all of those lines there's
five lines in between in between each
bmi unit so each one must be point two
so i'm going to go across to where 15
year old boys are
right which is if i draw my horizontal
line
it's going to look something like this
so 15 that's a vertical line
so you can see it's going to be here
a higher bmi means you have more mass
in proportion to your height right so a
low bmi
means um you're tall and skinny and a
higher bmi means
the other thing okay so okay accurate
uh reasonably yeah no no no who knows
you can go look it up it also changes
like this kind of thing doesn't take
into account
yeah that sounds about right yeah it
doesn't take into account things like
um you know ethnicity matters and you
know
what what time period you've grown up in
like just think about this right
you're like a bodybuilder yeah that's
right well you you aren't going to
factor into this
like that's true so mass like muscle's
heavier than weight
that's right it's still in the ballpark
okay so what's my answer what have i got
here what percentile am i on
i'm on the 10th percentile right
so what percentage of 15 boys have a
body mass index that's less than 17.1
10. now just before i leave this
question what if i answered and
asked it rather in the other direction
if one said what percentage of 15
year-old boys
have a body mass index that is greater
than 17.1 what would be your answer
it'd be it'd be everything above 10
which is 90 of the population does that
make sense
so um i've read across from 17.1
over here and i've gone all the way
across to 15 years old which is which is
here
that makes sense oh yeah yeah because
you have the line yeah yep
cool okay can you have a go part c
without me holding your hand have a go